- 90 plus percent of winning in anything
you try to do in America today
you got to be excited.
See if you want to win
folks you got to stand up
and you got to say I'm so sick and tired
of being average and ordinary.
I never forgave them for what they did
to my mama and what they
did to me and Angela.
And I was out to punish 'em.
The first few plays are critical.
You got to hit him hard
and show him who's boss.
If you understand this one sentence
you're guaranteed to be wealthy.
- He's the founder of A.L.
Williams and Associates
known as Primerica since 1991.
He built A.L. Williams and Associates
to be the largest seller of life insurance
in the United States.
In 2008 Forbes estimated his net worth
to be 1.4 billion dollars.
He's Art Williams and here's my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Rule number four is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick around all the way
to the end for some special bonus clips.
Also as Art is talking
if he says something
that really resonates with you
make sure to leave it
in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
others can be inspired as well.
90 plus percent of winning
in anything you try
to do in America today
you got to be excited.
People of America won't follow a bleebin,
a naggity, dull, disillusioned frustrated
dad gum cry baby.
People want people that are positive
and excited and enthusiastic and tough.
The greatest lesson.
The greatest definition I ever heard.
I thought about this 10 million times
when I wanted to quit
along the way of a winner,
this guy said almost everybody in America
can stay excited for two or three months.
A few people can stay excited
for two or three years
but a winner will stay
excited for 30 years
or ever how long it takes to win.
See if you want to win folks
you got to stand up and you got to say
I'm so sick and tired of
being average and ordinary.
I'm so sick and tired of telling my self
and telling my wife and telling my mama
and telling everybody I'm going to win.
I found it this time.
Watch my smoke.
See folks if you going to
win, you going to change,
the only way you can change life,
the only way the future can be better
than the past is you got to change.
Nobody can change for you.
Okay nobody's going to give
you something for nothing.
It's going to be up to you.
You're controlling your future
and if you don't change just
look in the dad gum mirror
look at the last five to
ten years of your life
and the next five or ten years
are going to be just like that.
Now ain't that depressing.
This thing that I adopted
nobody wants a boss
but everybody wants a coach.
You know if you're going
to be a great leader
and you're going to lead
your people to great success.
You've got to have a coach's heart
and a coach is trained to
look for the good things
in people you know everybody,
every piece of flesh that's ever been born
at one time in their life are dreamers.
They felt good about themselves
but do you realize that
90 percent of the people
that you recruit in business today,
on the outside they might look confident
but inside folks they've been crushed.
They've lost their confidence.
People have treated 'em bad.
They've almost given up on themselves
and it's your ability as
a coach to look inside
those people and see something good
and help them to believe
in themselves again.
To feel good about themselves again.
This going to determine
how far you take your team.
I believe the desire and
will to win is everything.
I don't know why I'm like I am
but my butt's always burnin'.
There's always say Art
dad gum it you're supposed
to go for it.
Art dad gum it you're
supposed to be somebody.
You're supposed to make a
difference with your life.
What does the $500,000 year person do
the $50,000 year person doesn't do?
You look at the outside and
study those two individuals,
everything seems to be the same.
They both are the same sex,
they're both the same age,
they have the same training,
the same positions, the same contract,
the same fringe benefits.
They both are successful, they work hard.
They're good family people.
Make tough commitments.
But what's the difference?
What is the $500,000 year person do
the $50,000 year person doesn't do?
He pays the price of a little bit more.
He works hard and a little bit more.
He's loyal to the company
need a little bit more.
He bleeds it a little bit more.
He makes money and a little bit more.
He saves money a little bit more.
If you want to win in these United States
you got to be tough and you can't quit.
The last thing I'll
talk to you about today
and building this winning edge
is folks if you want to win in business
you got to be a leader.
Leadership is everything.
You show me anything
in these United States
that win I'll show you a leader at work.
You show me a successful
church boy scout troop,
club, football team, business,
I'll show you some a run by leader.
See I thought at one time in my life
you had to be smart to win.
I used to have these smart people
that dress so pretty and talk so pretty
and use these big words.
They just intimidated me.
I said Art you can't ever be that good.
Why don't you just throw in the towel
and go and back and coach football
for a living and I found two things
out about smart people.
I think it's almost impossible
for a smart person to win in
business in America today.
Because I find smart people
spend their whole lifetime
figuring things out.
They also try to figure out an easier
way and a quicker way.
And another thing I found
out about smart people
is they just don't get
around to doin' nothin'.
And see somebody like Art Williams.
Everybody said well he can't do it.
Somebody like that can't do it.
But he does it.
See folks I want you to know
almost everybody in America
almost does enough to win.
They almost get there.
They almost are over the hump.
They almost have it goin'.
They almost in everything they do.
Almost is a way of life to
almost everybody in America.
But the winners do it.
What do they do?
They do whatever it takes
to get the job done.
They do it and do it and do it and do it
until the job gets done.
And then they talk about how
great it is to be somebody
they're proud of.
We need leaders in America who can do it.
If you want to become somebody do it.
If you want to go in
business for yourself do it.
If you want to become
financially independent do it.
I hear too much talk
in these United States
everybody can talk a good game.
We need people in America who can do it.
I go all over this
country with A.L. Williams
and I have people say
Art you can count on me.
Wonderful just do it.
Art I guarantee this is my last stop.
I'm going to win now.
Super duper just do it.
Art if I could just have one good month
and get the ball goin' I
know I could make it big.
Super just do it.
Art if I could just pay off
this debt I could really go.
Great just do it.
Art if I could just sell my house do it.
But houses ain't sellin'.
Do it anyway.
Art I'm not makin' any money
what can I do?
You just do it.
Do what Art?
You do it and do it and do it.
Art I guarantee I'm going
to win this contest.
Super duper just do it.
Art I'm over the hump now watch my smoke.
Great just do it.
Art I want to make it
so bad I can taste it.
What do I do?
You just do it.
Art I'm a Vice President
now can I quit doin' it?
Nope.
Art I don't know if I
can keep on keepin' on.
I'm really hurtin' what do I do?
You just do it?
Do what Art?
You do it and do it and do it.
Art all my life I've wanted
to be somebody important.
well do it then.
Art I'm going to save money so I don't
have to go through this again.
Great just do it.
Art I don't fee like
I've had enough training
what I do?
You just do it.
Art my manager don't give
me no help what I do?
You just do it.
Art you don't understand
I was Mr. Everything
at my former company
you don't mean I have to
start off down at the
bottom and do it do you?
Yep you really got to do it.
Art what's the primary difference
between winners and losers?
The winners do it.
They do it and do it and do it and do it
until the job gets done.
And then they talk about how great it is
to have finally achieved something unique.
And how glad they are
that they didn't quit
like everybody else.
And how wonderful it is
to finally be somebody
they're proud of.
And make a difference with their life.
The key to winning is not talent.
It's not looks.
It's not degrees.
I believe the key to
winning is being the best
you can possibly be.
I believe if you're
proud of your abilities
and your opportunity.
If you look in the mirror and you say
that guy's supposed to win you know.
He's supposed to be somebody you know
and you go out there and you go fight
and you be the best you can be.
You're going to have a lot
of defeats along the way.
You're going to be in so many situations
that look hopeless but if you just keep
being the best you can be.
It's going to look impossible at time.
Just keep being the best you can be
all you can do is all you can do.
But all you can do is enough.
When we found out that
cash value of life insurance
was a rip off of
and buy term and invest the difference
was the way to go
and they had screwed our family,
I'm tellin' you what
I never forgave them for
what they did to my mama
and what they did to me and Angela
and I was out to punish them.
I wanted to hurt them.
And that's the way the
A.L. Williams people were.
And the more they tried to destroy us.
With just millions of
wars that we went through.
When you're a crusader,
crusaders die hard.
And so it just made us more determined
to show them you know
we wasn't going to let the enemy
you know defeat us you know.
Another key to building this winning edge
in this mental toughness
is you've got to become a dreamer again.
I'm a Methodist and we
just changed ministers
a few weeks ago and our
new minister came in
and the church was just packed.
The first thing he said is well looks
like everybody came out
to see the monkey perform
and the second thing out of his mouth
he said for a church to be a great church,
you got to have a dream.
If you don't have a dream you're dead
and boy I sat up and I said
man me and this guy
going to get along good
'cause he knows what he's talkin' about.
See folks I believe in order to win
you got to feel good about yourself.
When I was coaching
football for seven years
back in Georgia and I had a paddle
in my coaching office
it was about this thick
and this long.
And in the fat end I had little holes
bored in it so you could really
get some speed and
blister their little butt
when they misbehaved
and I had a rule on my football team
that if any kid said I can't,
if any football player heard
one of my football players
said I can't.
He got to bring him in the coaches office
and give him three licks
and it took me about a month
to get all that thinking out of my players
every year you know
and I'd have football
players knock on my door
at recess and at lunch and after school
and he said coach he said it.
Coach he said it.
And I'd make that kid bend over
and I'd give that other kid the board
and he would bust him three times
and folks it didn't take long you
couldn't create a word game
to get one of my kids to say I can't
bring it home a little more personal when
April and little Art were just this little
and could understand words every time
they said I can't I made
them do three push ups.
Folks there ain't nothing you can't do
in America if you want to bad enough.
A.L. Williams didn't invent buy term
and invest the difference
but we were the first
group of people that took that crusade
to the American consumer
out there you know?
And yes that's why we're number one.
I believe the first step
to winning in business
is you got to do what's right
for the consumer out there.
I believe your reputation's everything.
If you don't do what's
right a hundred percent
of the time you might get
by for one day, one week,
one month, one year but sooner or later
they're going to smell you out.
Well folks buy term invest the difference
is right and we've stood the heat like
you couldn't believe and
that's why we're number one.
I tell our kids I say now fellas
you know football is not a team game.
It is and it ain't.
See football is really a game against you
and that guy in a wrong colored jersey
lining up across from you.
Somebody's going to win.
You or him.
And the person that wins is
going to want it the most.
This business is nothin'
but an attitude business.
See you got to prepare to win.
The first few plays are critical.
You've got to hit him hard
and show him who's boss.
So see somebody's going
to quit, you or him.
And you got to look for every weakness.
See when he starts
sweatin' hard you know you
got him on the run, hit him hard
knock him out and we chalk him up.
If he starts breathin' hard you know
he's suckin' eggs, hit him hard
knock him out and we chalk him up.
If he starts bleedin'
you know you about got him.
Hit him hard knock him
out and we chalk him up.
I said don't you ever
show weakness out there.
I never let one of my teams
get down on their knees.
I said at time out you turn
and look the enemy in the eye.
You watch him on his knee.
When he takes his hat off you
see how much he's sweating.
You watch and see how
much water he drinks.
You know you got him hurting, hit him
and knock him out and we chalk him up.
I'm going to give you my entire
management philosophy folks
that I developed over 19
years in one sentence.
I'm going to boil everything
down in one sentence.
If you understand this one sentence
you're guaranteed to be wealthy.
I was in Philadelphia three weeks ago
during this super seminar
with 10,000 termites
just like in this arena here.
In Philadelphia this is
the 200th year celebration
of signing our Constitution.
Everybody's flooding into Philly.
It's a fun place to go right now.
On every corner in Philadelphia
you know they've got statues
of George Washington and Benjamin Franklin
and Thomas Jefferson and they
got all these famous sayings
of all these great American heroes.
But you know what?
- [Audience] What?
- There's probably
never been a human being
on the face of this Earth
that's ever said anything
as smart as I'm fixing to tell you.
Hey listen.
Folks this is the answer.
The total answer to being
successful in business.
This is the management
philosophy that will
make you a superstar in business.
Can you believe that an old football coach
with a P.E. degree and an average IQ
could think of something so brilliant.
Now think about this folks.
Think about this.
How may pieces of flesh
have lived on this earth?
Nobody knows right.
But do you know as much as I can determine
I am the single human being that's
lived on this earth that said this first.
Hey listen.
There's probably never been
a more brilliant statement
uttered from the lips of a human being
than what I'm fixing to tell ya.
Hey listen, listen, listen.
Now listen probably one day
you're going to see a
monument to Art Williams
and it's going to have this
dad gum statement on it.
Hey folks do you understand
what I'm tellin' you?
I'm tellin' you a management
philosophy in one sentence
that guarantees you to be
a superstar in business.
Hey listen, listen.
Do you know Benjamin Franklin
ain't ever said nothing
compared to what I'm fixing to tell you
today in Chicago.
(audience cheers)
Alright.
Alright listen.
Listen.
You going to miss it.
This is pure genius.
Folks this is all there is
wrapped up in one sentence.
Nine words.
Guaranteed to make you wealthy.
You ready?
(audience cheers)
Going to save you thousands and thousands
of hours of agony and frustration.
Are you ready?
Alright here it is.
Here it is.
My entire management philosophy listen.
The whole ball game guaranteed
to make you a super star.
Here it is.
All you can do is all you can do.
Hey!
(audience cheers)
Hey is that brilliant?
Now listen is that brilliant?
Okay listen.
Is that unbelievable?
Okay listen, listen.
Listen.
Now listen.
Alright listen now listen.
Listen now listen.
Listen.
Alright listen.
Hold up, hold up, listen.
Hold up now.
Hold up.
Alright hold on.
Alright listen, listen.
Listen.
Alright listen now folks I'm fixing
to give it to you now listen.
Most important thing you'll ever hear
in business in America today now.
All you can do is all you can do.
There ain't nothin' more
than all you can do.
That is the absolute maximum.
You can't do no more than all you can do.
You understand that?
All you can do is all you can do.
All you can do is everything.
That's the absolute ultimate right?
But the second part of that saying.
Is all you can do is all you can do
but all you can do is enough.
- Thank you guys so much for watching
I made this video because Jujuan Peel
asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Art's top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why.
How is it going to change
your life or your business?
Leave it in the comments and
I will join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for
watching continue to believe
or whatever your one word
is and I 'll see you soon.
- The system must be simple.
You know when I was coaching football
I thought I was a
quarterback in high school,
a quarterback in college
and I was assistant coach
down in Thomasville Georgia.
When I got my first head coaching job
I had a play book that
was about this thick.
Man I had everything figured out.
I was an offensive whiz you know?
And when I went to my first coaching job
I had this complicated playbook you know
and all that kind of stuff.
I was a head coach for
five years in Georgia.
In my last year when
we won the championship
my play book was seven pages thick.
The system's got to be simple.
It's got to be simple.
I used this example about
prudential rate book
when we kicked their butt
1984 look at that rate book.
It was one inch thick.
They had dozens and dozens of
different kind of products.
This is A.L. Williams rate book.
One page.
We had one product.
We sold the consumer term insurance.
We sold term insurance a hundred percent
of the dad gum time.
We sold everybody the same dad gum product
we own and our dad gum line.
Ain't that the kind of company
you want to be part of?
You know you might not like us.
You might not come to work with us.
You might not buy or dad gum product
but you never have to back in the door
when you belong to A.L. Williams.
We do whats right for
the consumer every time.
We say what we own on
our own life every time.
It's got to be simple.
And the bigger you get
the more complicated
your job gets.
You've got to have
ability to keep it simple
and to spend.
I use this little formula
90 percent of your time
on important things.
Important things in our business
are always the people things
and that's what you do
when you're starting out.
You're dealing with people.
You're recruiting people.
You're motivating people
you're building friends
with your people and
then all of the sudden
you get into compliance and
you get into administration
and your job becomes more
meetings and planning
and all this kind of crap you know?
And before you know it
you're spending 10 percent
of your time on important stuff.
People.
And 90 percent of your
time on administrative
paper work all this kind of crap
that doesn't make any money.
You've got to constantly
strive to keep your business
simple and to focus and spend your time
on important things.
Another key in building this winning edge
is folks you've got to
stand for something.
People in America, the
good people in America
are fed up with here with these dad gum
fence sitters and mealy mouths.
Corporate America has an especially black
eye in business today.
Most people in America think
you can't find a company.
They think you can't find a sales person
that'll tell you like it is
and stand behind the word.
They think companies will sell anything,
say anything just to make a sale.
Just to make a profit.
You know what folks if you want to win
in the free enterprise
system in America today,
you got to stand for something.
Folks the difference in the great coaches
and the average and ordinary coaches
is the ability to get
momentum and to keep momentum.
Think about this folks A.L. Williams
for 20 consecutive years grew.
Now during those 20 consecutive years
we changed companies five times.
I had to terminate the number one producer
in our company on two different occasions
and it was almost
impossible to get terminated
from A.L. Williams.
We had wars with the regulators.
We were kicked out of
Mississippi for two weeks.
Canada passed a rule where there was no
part time recruits.
Texas limited the number
of recruits we could,
350 a year.
With all of that A.L. Williams
grew for 20 straight years.
Now how do you grow?
This is the difference in a pro.
A real pro and an average
and ordinary coach.
There are three things you do now
to guarantee you keep momentum
when you get it goin'.
Number one you grow by multiplication.
You grow by multiplication.
You've got to always be promoting people.
To district leader to division leader
to RVP okay because once
you get things growin
by multiplication,
then what you have are
you have hundreds then,
hundreds of thousands of people that are
doing what you are trying to do okay?
Building friends.
Praise and recognizing people.
Recruiting best friends.
Does that make sense?
And so once you're
growing by multiplication,
that's the greatest opportunity for you
to keep that momentum that you've kept.
Okay?
That make sense?
Alright number two.
The second thing in keeping this momentum
once you have it is you've
got to have an enemy.
You've got to have some
kind of injustice out there.
You're trying to create.
You've got to have an edge.
I don't care
if you're in the real
estate business right?
If somebody's chargin' let's
say a 10 percent commission
on just raw land that you sell out there,
then you do it for
eight and a half percent
or something you've got to
have an edge over the enemy.
You've got to have an enemy you're trying
to beat out there right?
Now we were fortunate
to have the worst enemy
in the whole history of the world right?
The trash value guys right?
But you're selling a crusade.
There's nothing that energizes people
and keep that momentum goin'
like a crusade right?
You're out there trying to save the world.
You're trying to make a
difference with your life right?
And then the third thing
is you have competition.
Competition inside the company.
I was a master in promoting competition
inside the company right?
Like Lawrence Walker I get
him taking on Dick Walker.
You know down in Tampa Florida.
I had a gift of always egging
people along a little bit.
So if you want to keep
momentum once you get it
there are three keys.
You grow by multiplication.
You keep recruiting.
Listen to this folks.
For 20 years as President
of A.L. Williams,
the first thing I look for everyday
on my desk, Kathy Harry my secretary
the first thing I did
when I went in the office
before I talked to Beau or anybody
and got in my million
things I needed to do okay?
The first thing I did every morning
was look at recruiting numbers.
First thing I did every morning.
The second thing I did was
sign 200 go-go letters.
That's the first thing I did
and got that out of the way.
First thing every morning right?
And so you've got to have way.
I'm going to talk to you about that
in a morning to monitoring
this kind of stuff
so when you know, you
anticipate when you are slowin'
down right when you're
fixing to hit a brick wall
down the road correct?
So if you're growin' by multiplication,
if you've got people out
there recruiting best friends.
You're picking up
policies of best friends,
making presentations to best friends.
Building friends with their recruits,
praising recognizing people.
Promoting district managers.
Promoting division managers,
promoting RVP's and you're teaching people
how to do all these same kind of things
to build these powerful
relationships right?
Then you're guaranteed
you're going to keep
that momentum going.
If you have an enemy
you've got to have an enemy,
you've got to have something you
can get people riled up about
and then the third things
is you create competition
inside your own organization
or inside the company right?